Dynamite by BTS.
BTS finally made the list.
They're nominated for a Grammy in the category of Best Pop Duo or Group Performance...
...for their hit English language single, Dynamite.
This is their first nomination for a Grammy and the first for a K-pop artist.
They have won honors, however, including this year at other major U.S. events...
including the Billboard Music Awards and the American Music Awards.
The band's huge fanbase known as Army are thrilled about the nomination...
...and are hoping it results in a win.
International media outlets like AP and Reuters called their nomination a breakthrough.
And Billboard went further, claiming that the Recording Academy which hosts the awards...
...has finally recognized a cultural shift in a major category.
The Grammys will be held on January 31st, 2021...
...and BTS will be competing for the prize against pop stars like Lady Gaga and Taylor Swift.